I got to tell you this culture has it's
got a victim mentality out there
floating around it's got a mentality
that's just nobody told me
and that's a valid thing because I've
got a lot of stuff nobody told me and
you know it leaves a scar you know that
kind of stuff but like you know some
[ __ ] tweeted awhile ago Dan Anthony
O'Neill's book is out debt-free degree
what's the book say just don't be poor
well little burg he's a little whiner a
little victim whiner just don't be poor
no the answer is don't be stupid we've
all been poor just about most of us at
one time or another actually I've never
been poor I've only been broke poor as a
state of mind and ER is your spirit
animal you know little men can't get
ahead we're just stuck and people like
me can't win and call the wambulance
seriously unbelievable you know no the
book gives you a step-by-step plan if
you're completely broke you have no
money your parents have no money we can
still show you how to go to school
completely debt-free now I'm gonna have
to put your little butt to work and I
know that's not gonna make you happy and
you're going to apply for scholarships
and maybe you're not gonna get to play
beer pong every night while you're in
school cuz you're gonna be working well
or you can go deeply in debt for a
degree in beer pong and that's what
people do so I mean really honestly how
you approach this and what you believe
to be true about life has a big part of
whether or not you hit these goals we
just gave you a ton of tools at Anthony
O'Neill comm including giving away
$10,000 and it's completely free
last I checked free is accessible if you
don't have any money we didn't charge
you a dime for that we've got borrowed
future
Casas in the top ten podcasts already on
Apple podcast started a week ago Monday
second episode dropped yesterday out of
10 episode of eight episodes and guess
what podcasts are free and I know you
have a phone so you could use it for
something positive because you were
tweeting whining so we know you have
access to the media social media good
lord
ah it's just sickening so here's the
thing we're going to show you exactly
how to do this stuff so you don't have
to be one of them one of the new victims
of Congress Congress is victimizing our
entire culture by continuing to make
these student loans if they're so bad
that we have to talk about forgiving
them lefties maybe you lefty should
introduce a bill that says no more
making the loans it's intellectual
dishonesty you talk about forgiving
something while you're still making the
loans we trying to create more victims
so you can get more voters when you help
them this is a false dichotomy people so
you got to stop it we have to stop these
loans and then one way to stop them is
you just stop taking them out another
way to stop them is Congress actually
grows brain cells well there's a wish
and it stops the thing so this is how
it's done you guys this is how it's done
but you know most of believing is
thinking you can and that's you know you
written guarantee you Henry Ford said if
you think you can or you think you can't
you're right and if you think it's
impossible to go to college without a
student loan you're gonna get a student
loan you're wrong but just your thought
patterns have screwed you your belief
system screwed you if you think it's
impossible for the little men to get
ahead you're gonna whine and claim
victim status the rest of your life and
you're always gonna be the little man
who didn't get ahead and it's always
gonna be Walmart
alter McDonald's didn't pay enough Oh
give me a break who got rich working at
McDonald's to start with unless just the
one you own in st. Thomas I mean really
is this your life goal seriously
the whining has to stop you got to start
looking into your future and seeing
something bright that can happen and
it's possible and it's doable
regardless of how you grew up regardless
of your race creed color or national
origin you can do this
people of all ilk sand backgrounds do it
so you can go to school debt-free